hi
so today i wanted to talk about the
neuroscience book the forgetting machine
by rodrigo kian cohica and i think this
book was really good it dives into the
topic of memory and how we are our
memory and then for example when we
change someone's memory that they really
change the person they are and so i
think this is a super popular topic
right now in media so for example you
see this in one of my favorite movies
blade runner and in blade runner they
are in this memory facility where they
try to create these artificial memories
what makes your memories so authentic
well
there's a bit of every artist in their
work
but i was locked in a sterile chamber a
day so
if i wanted to see the world i had to
imagine it
so memory really makes us who we are and
that's why you get these super sad
stories of how people with alzheimer's
for example are not recognized anymore
by their family because their memory
loss
really makes them lose a part of their
selves so the science of memory is
really this transcendence between mind
and matter and rodrigo tries to describe
in his book all the different facets of
memory and how they make us who we are
so i want to dive into three topics that
he discusses in his book from how
memories are made from our vision to
memory fallacies and in the end a little
bit about the jennifer aniston neuron
which is rodrigo's own work and i hope
you will learn a little bit more about
memory along the way and i also highly
recommend of course to read the book if
you're interested in any of this work so
he starts his first chapter with
information theory and vision and that's
because what we actually remember is of
course what we record right but the
interesting thing is that we don't
really record like a camera so we don't
have the full picture in sharp focus at
all times but we actually only see with
a tiny part of our eye or a tiny part of
our visual field is in high spatial
resolution and this is the visual fovea
and the fovea is this small depression
within a neurosensory retina where the
visual equity is the highest so the
interesting thing is that even though we
have the feeling that we see our full
visual field in focus we actually only
see the center in focus or the point
where we focus on and we get the full
visual feel because our eyes are making
these tiny zakats through the visual
space and that then records the entire
visual field so our brain is actually
constructing this entire image of a full
in focus visual field and this is also
the reason that magicians for example
can do their tricks quite easily because
we actually don't see as much as we
think we see so if they then diverge our
attention to a certain part in the
visual field they can easily do their
trick in another part because we're
actually not recording that part even
though our brain is constructing this
image that we see the entire visual
field so it's for example then quite
interesting that when we look at faces
we have the idea that we see the entire
face as a whole we actually record parts
of the face in sequence so we first look
at the eyes for example then the nose
and then the mouth and then the brain
makes an entire face of it and something
that i find quite interesting is that
some artists have picked up on this may
it be because they have some knowledge
of neuroscience or because they just
thought about this but for example
picasso does this a lot in his pictures
where he focuses on each part of the
face in detail and then makes a kind of
abstract face from it although it is
probably a little bit closer to how we
actually see in real life so rodrigo
then says that the eye does not see what
the brain does and then our memories
because our memories are created from
what the eye is seeing or what our
senses are feeling our memories are then
not like a camera but a little bit more
like a book that was written by the
brain and he actually gives this super
nice quote from aristotle that i want to
read for you guys a little bit thinking
is different from perceiving and is held
to be in part imagination impart
judgment but what we imagine is
sometimes false though our
contemporaneous judgment about it is
true so rodrigo then says that based on
past experiences our brain constructs
our current reality and this is again a
little bit this idea of the bayesian
brain where we update our priors by new
information we get such that our
estimations of the current reality are
as accurate as possible so we can
already see from this chapter that our
memory is a little bit faulty so he then
delves into the fact that the confidence
we have in our memories is actually not
really possible lenny you can't trust a
man's life to your little notes and
pictures why not because your notes
could be unreliable memories on of malia
oh please no no no no really memory's
not perfect it's not even that good ask
the police eyewitness testimony is
unreliable
cops don't catch a killer by sitting
around remembering stuff right they
collect facts
they make notes and they draw
conclusions facts not memories so he
goes into this case of robert cotton
which i want to
show you guys a little bit because i
think it's a super good example of how
our faulty memories can really destroy
another person's life and why you should
never be a hundred percent confident in
memories you have because our memory
system is so tricky so the case goes
like this in 1984 jennifer thompson a
college student in north carolina was
raped by a person who broke into her
home with a knife to her throat unable
to escape thompson decided to focus on
her rapist face and remember every one
of his traits and features so that
someday if she survived the attack she
would be able to identify him and secure
his conviction thompson examined the
photographs in the police office for
about five minutes before she identified
ronald cotton she was convinced that she
identified her rapist but she was wrong
at the age of 22 ronald cotton was
sentenced to life in prison but sometime
later by chance the prison admitted a
serial rapist who resembles ronald's
cotton bobby poole cotton heard that
paul was the man who actually raped
jennifer thompson and this was later
confirmed by dna analysis however when
jennifer thompson was confronted by the
fact that it couldn't have been robert
cotton that committed to crime but it
was actually bobby poole as confirmed by
dna analysis she confirmed that she
still saw robert cotton's face when she
looked back on this memory so what
rodrigo actually think happened is that
jennifer thompson replaced her memory of
fool by cotton because she saw the
picture of cotton street after her case
happened and this is something that our
brain does a lot we replace pictures or
we replace stories into our own
narrative so our memory is literally
just written by our brain and it could
be anything and then his the final part
of his book goes a little bit more into
research that he did himself and i think
this research is amazing so i would also
highly recommend to read the following
two papers of his if you like this kind
of research and that is concept cells
the building blocks of declarative
memory functions and plugging into human
memory so i will put both of them down
below in the resources if you want to
read them so his research is about this
jennifer aniston neuron and it made a
huge wave in the neuroscience community
when it was fined now that these kind of
neurons exist the jennifer aniston
neuron reacts to a name and pictures of
a person showing that these neurons
react to super specific concepts so
these neurons are made by these
intracranial recordings of people with
epilepsy an intercranial means that a
part of the skull is removed and we
literally make the recordings directly
from the brain and this is so much more
valuable for example than eg or fmri
data because usually with this type of
data there's a lot more noise whereas
these intracranial recordings have a lot
less noise so in this case they did the
intracranial recordings from the medial
temporal lobe and the medial temporal
lobe includes the hippocampus amygdala
para hippocampal regions and is crucial
for episodic and spatial memory so they
then recorded the neurons of awake
participants in this region and then one
of the first such neurons found so the
jennifer anison neuron was in the
hippocampus and it fired to seven
different pictures of the actors
jennifer aniston and not to 80 other
pictures of known and unknown people
animals in our places so it actually
reacted to these super specific pictures
of jennifer aniston and they later also
saw that it reacted to pictures of for
example co-workers of jennifer aniston
and her name and everything related to
the concept jennifer aniston and that is
why these neurons are now called
jennifer aniston neurons in the popular
media but they're also called concept
neurons more formally and these neurons
then record actually certain concepts so
in his paper he gives this super good
example i think of luke skywalker and
then these neurons react to the concept
of luke skywalker or the concept of star
wars and then for example these neurons
would also react if we show the
participants a picture of yoda or a
picture of darth vader if they have the
concept of star wars so rodrigo then
thinks that such partially overlapping
representation could be the basis of the
encoding and learning of associations of
episodic memory episodic memory is
defined as the ability to recall and
mentally re-experience specific episodes
from one's personal past so yeah i think
these single cell recordings really
taught us a lot about how we actually
learn so we already know from experience
that a lot of people learn in concepts
so we relate new information to all the
information we have in this kind of
concept frame but by the single cell
recordings we also actually saw this
pattern emerge in neurons whereas before
we couldn't really see this because for
example the neurons in our visual fields
just react to basic visual features but
we see then that the neurons in the
temporal medial lobe actually react to
these higher cognition features so yeah
that was the book i wanted to talk about
today and if you have any
recommendations for me what to read next
i would love to hear them so put them
down below and otherwise see you next
week bye